for example in Wisconsin you can make a
citizen's arrest if you hear someone say
they don't want fries with that in
Nashville Tennessee a young person
coming to town with a guitar must have
at least one pocketful of Dreams in
Philadelphia a cheesesteak can hold
elected office in Detroit Michigan
if you kill a Juggalo you must use every
part of the Juggalo in New Orleans it's
illegal for a physician to administer a
breast exam without first presenting the
patient with a string of beads in Omaha
Nebraska
it's a misting it's a misdemeanor to
pester annoy or insult the corn in Aspen
Colorado it's illegal to shred the NAR
if pow-pow levels of low mondo
in the Bronx New York you must run
everything by Lu in West Virginia it's
illegal to marry your sibling no joke
here just a reminder in Florida it is
illegal to eat any faces after 10 p.m.
[Applause]
in Texarkana you can be arrested for
saying the word quinoa instead of using
its proper name gay rice in rural
Alabama Wow look at you look like
somebody to the wrong turn
[Applause]
and finally in Mississippi it's
considered sodomy to let your torch
touch another man's torch at a Klan
rally
[Applause]
you